>> Tucker: WOW, ANDREW CUOMO'S
LIFE BLEW UP TODAY.
HE IS A VERY WEIRD GUY.
YOU KNOW THAT IF YOU WATCH HIM
ON TELEVISION.
IF YOU TALK TO HIM IN PERSON, WE
APOLOGIZE, WE KNOW ANDREW CUOMO
HAS SOME SECRETS.
EARLIER SEVERAL WOMEN ACCUSED
HIM OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT AND THE
MEDIA TREATED THAT LIKE A BIGGER
SCANDAL THAN THE FACT THAT
GOVERNO
GOVERNOR CUOMO CAUSED DEATHS OF
SENIORS IN NURSING HOMES.
ANDREW CUOMO IS A BIG BELIEVER
IN THE "ME TOO" MOVEMENT.
TODAY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
COMPLETED THE INVESTIGATION INTO
ANDREW CUOMO'S SERIAL CREEPNESS.
HE VIOLATED MULTIPLE STATE AND
FEDERAL LAWS.
>> THE INVESTIGATION FOUND THAT
GOVERNOR CUOMO SEXUALLY HARASSED
CURRENT AND FORMER NEW YORK
STATE EMPLOYEES BY ENGAGING IN
UNWELCOME TOUCHING AND MAKE
OFFENSIVE COMMENTS OF
A SUGGESTIVE AND SEXUAL NATURE.
>> THE GOVERNOR'S PARTERN OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT WAS NOT
LIMITED TO MEMBERS OF HIS OWN
STAFF, BUT EXTENDED TO OTHER
STATE EMPLOYEES INCLUDING
A STATE TROOPER WHO SERVED ON
HIS PROTECTIVE DETAIL.
SOME SUFFERED THROUGH UNWANTED
TOUCHING AND GRABBING OF THEIR
MOST INTIMATE BODY PARTS.
>> THE GOVERNOR HUGGED EXECUTIVE
ASSISTANT NUMBER 1 AND REACHED
UNDER HER BLOUSE TO GRAB HER
BREAST.
THIS WAS A PATTERN OF I
INAPPROPRIATE SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
HE RAN HIS HANDS UP AND DOWN HER
BACK.
HE GRABBED HER BUTT.
>> Tucker: WASN'T JOE BIDEN
ACCUSED OF THAT?
WE ARE PRETENDING THAT DIDN'T
HAPPEN.
ANDREW CUOMO IS NOT AGAINST
DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
HE WANTS TO HAVE SEX WITH THEM
OR AT LEAST ONE OF THEM.
YOU CAN FIND THIS REPULSIVE AND
FIND ANDREW CUOMO REPULSIVE.
IT'S OKAY TO DISLIKE EVERYBODY
INVOLVED.
THE REPORT FOUND THAT GOVERNOR
CUOMO WAS SEXUALLY ATTRACTED TO
HIS EMMY STATUE.
HOW IS THAT FOR WEIRD?
TWO WITNESSES SAID THAT HE
LOOKED AT HIS EMMY STATUE HE WON
IN NOVEMBER OF 2020 AND SAID,
LOOK AT HER FIGURE.
ISN'T SHE BUXOM?
[LAUGHING] THIS IS A TOTAL CREEP
FOR REAL -- BUT YOU KNEW THAT.
ANOTHER EXHIBIT SHOWS CHRIS
CUOMO OF CNN DRAFTED A STATEMENT
FOR HIS BROTHER WHICH HIS
BROTHER USED.
CNN FLACKING FOR THE GOVERNOR OF
NEW YORK TO DEFENDING HIMSELF
AGAINST SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
HE DIDN'T CLAIM ANTI-ITALIAN
BIAS WHICH HE CLAIMED IN THE
PASS.
HE SAID HE IS NOT RESIGNING.
HE SHOWED A SLIDE SHOW OF
HIMSELF KISSING PEOPLE INCLUDING
AL GORE.
>> I NEVER TOUCHED ANYONE
INAPPROPRIATELY OR MADE
INAPPROPRIATE SEXUAL ADVANCES.
I AM 63 YEARS OLD.
I HAVE LIVED MY ENTIRE ADULT
LIFE IN PUBLIC VIEW.
THAT IS JUST NOT WHO I AM.
THAT'S NOT WHO I HAVE EVER BEEN.
>> Tucker: WE DIDN'T SHOW THE
TAPE BUT THE SLIDE SHOW THAT
CUOMO PUT ON THE SCREEN SHOWED
HIM HUGGING AL GORE BUT NOT
REACHING UNDER GORE'S SHIRT TO
GRAB HIS MAN'S BOOBS.
WE ARE NOT SURE WHAT TO MAKE OF
ALL OF THIS.
FRANCIE IS A FORMER FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR AND JOINS US.
HOW WOULD ASSESS WHAT WE JUST
LEARNED ABOUT GOVERNOR CREEPO?
>> WELL, I THINK GOVERNOR CUOMO
IS IN A LOT OF TROUBLE.
IT'S CONVENIENT HE SAID THAT'S
NOT WHO I AM.
THAT'S A CLASSIC NON-DENIAL WE
HEAR FROM SEX OFFENDERS.
HE EMPHASIZ
ATHIZED WIT
BUT CALL THEM A LIAR.
YOU CAN'T HAVE IT BOTH WAYS.
ONE WOMAN HE SAID HE FELT SO
MUCH SYMPATHY FOR HER IT WAS
DISCUSSING.
EVERYONE TALKS ABOUT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND UNWANTING
TOUCHING, BUT GRABBING SOMEONE
IN THEIR BREAST AREA OR BUTT,
THOSE ARE BATTERY, ASSAULT AND
SEXUAL BATTERIES.
THOSE ARE CRIMES.
THAT'S VERY DIFFERENT FROM
A CIVIL CASE WHICH IS WHAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IS TALKING
ABOUT TODAY.
>> Tucker: SO, I HATE TO BORROW
THE WORDS OF THE "ME TOO"
MOVEMENT.
WHAT THIS ESTABLISHES IS
A PATTERN OVER TIME OF SEXUALLY
AGGRESSIVE BEHAVIOR IN THE
OFFICE OF ONE OF THE MOST
LIBERAL GOVERNORS IN AMERICA.
ASK ANY WOMAN WHO HAS DATED
A LIBERAL MAN, THEY ARE TERRIBLE
TO DATE.
THEY MISTREAT WOMEN.
WHY DID NOBODY IN THE OFFICE
REPORT THIS UNTIL NOW?
WHY DID IT TAKE YEARS?
>> THAT'S AN INTERESTING
QUESTION.
IT'S ABOUT POWER.
WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEONE IN A POWER
POSITION, A GOVERNOR WHO IS
TALKED ABOUT AS A PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE.
EVEN WOMEN WOULD RATHER RUN
WOMEN DOWN FOR THEIR OWN
CAREERS.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR THEIR OWN
KOREAN ADVANCEMENT.
THEY ARE WILLING TO PROTECT THE
GOVERNOR.
WHAT HE SAID ABOUT KISSING AL
GORE IS A RIDICULOUS EXCUSE AND
YOU CONSIDER THAT SEXUAL BATTERY
AND HARASSMENT NEVER TAKE PLACE
IN THE PUBLIC EYE.
ISN'T IT CONVENIENT HE BUILT FOR
HIMSELF A TOUCHY REPUTATION?
DID HE DO THAT SO THAT HE COULD
CLAIM LATER THAT THESE WERE ALL
MISINTERPRETED TOUCHINGS AND HE
IS JUST AN AFFECTIONATE MAN.
>> Tucker: I KISSED AL GORE IS
NOT A DEFENSE.
THAT'S AN ADMISSION OF GUILT.
EVEN TIPPER HAD ENOUGH OF THIS.
YOU ARE WEIRD.